When you need new software,
what do you typically do?
You might visit an app store
like this and download it or
you could actually walk into a store and
buy a physical copy.
You have a lot of different options.
You might even say you
have a list of options.
Now how often have you seen software for
Linux sitting up on a store shelf?
Not very often, if at all.
But we still have a list of various
places we can go to get software.
This is called a package source list.
Let's take a look.
All of your available package
sources are listed in this file
/etc/app/sources.list.
Remember when we were
discussing distributions,
we said each one approves and
releases packages in their own way and
that's one of the big ways
in which they differ.
This is the package's list for
your current version of Ubuntu.
As you skim through the file, you'll
see some pretty recognizable parts.
We see a URL here and
the word trusty looks familiar.
That's the code name for
the version of Ubuntu we're running.
We know Ubuntu is also
based off of Debian, so
that's probably what this deb stands for
here.
This is a list of software repositories
that Ubuntu set up for us automatically.
There are a lot in this list and
each of these would be referenced
when you try to update or
install new software.
Speaking of which, let's go ahead and
make sure that all of our
software is up to date.